on a reçu des tonnes de questions sur
les finances personnelles dans les
derniers jours avec toute la volatilité
des marchés bien sûr on répond à vos
questions ce soir avec 110 la chapelle
qui et planificatrice financière
indépendante bonsoir samedi la chapelle
non ça c'est fini merci d'être avec nous
pour répondre à quelques-unes des
questions je mentionne aussi que notre
balade aux questions d'intérêt sera
consacrée avec vous à des questions et à
des réponses sur tout mais tout de suite
ce soir quelques questions on commence
avec une première nous sommes âgés de 55
et 65 ans serait-il plus sage de cesser
de cotiser à nourrir et celi pour
quelques temps étant donné la descente
des marchés qu'en pensez vous donc c'est
une question qui comprenait considère un
large des auditeurs donc on se met en
contexte de prix retraite ça peut
sembler inquiétant de plongée dans un
marché aussi volatil que le marché
actuel
par contre je vous rappelle une des
règles de succès en investissement qui
est de ne pas essayer d'anticiper le
marché donc je dirais oui il faut
continuer à investir chaque personne
doit continuer à investir selon son
profil d'investisseur son horizon
placement sa situation personnelle
donc il ya des façons de faire ces
investissements l'homme est de toute
évidence le marché favorables au nouveau
à chaud actuellement donc beaucoup plus
exactement donc pour les reér 2020 at en
dépôt à la fin de l'année 2020 si vous
avez des liquidités je comprends que en
situation de crise économique pour
certaines personnes c'est impossible
actuellement
mais si vous avez des liquidités
disponibles j'incite les gens
acheter actuellement et même mon bureau
on commence à voir des appels de gens
qui veulent faire des prêts avec des
investissements des prêts levier pour
investir donc on sent que quand même un
certain optimisme dans le marché des
investisseurs
mais il faut toujours se respecter avec
leur propre profil et notre propre
stress comprends mais madame la chapelle
on sait pas faire baisser de combien
encore en fait on ne sait pas
effectivement on s'attend à ce que ça va
être encore avoir la remontée donc il
faut comme je vous y faut respecter ce
moment-là son sa capacité de tolérer la
volatilité qui va user en une personne à
la deuxième question nous sommes
retraités et on voit nos placements
tomber en flèche sur été mieux de les
sortir et investir dans des placements
sécurisés
notre question que je que je comprend
actuellement donc mais évidemment la
réponse serait de ne pas faire ça juste
à titre d'exemple quelqu'un qui aurait
investi dix mille dollars en 2000 à 2006
lorsque a eu la dernière correction
boursière quelques années après son
placement vallées alpines 7500 quelqu'un
qui aurait fait ce genre de décision
aujourd'hui aurait en main 9000 $ alors
que quelqu'un qui serait resté dans le
marché depuis aurait plus de 21 mille
dollars dans le même placement donc on
parle d'un portefeuille équilibré
donc être libre et mondialement effet je
comprends la panique des investisseurs
on a tous une tolérance au risque
j'ai le goût de dire aux gens qu'ils qui
vivent sortir des inquiétudes de
communiquer avec leur conseiller
c'est le travail des conseillers en
placement de distinguer livre les
risques véritables il y risque escompté
par lee et les investissements au niveau
plus rondement il ya plusieurs questions
jusqu'au 29 juin la valeur de l'action
du fonds ftq restera 46 dollars 20 lb
sera radicalement à compter du 30 juin
au moment du dépôt de leur rapport
biannuel devrait transférer
immédiatement le montant de serrières
vers celui de mon institution bancaire
afin de protéger à la fois mon capital
et mes intérêts accumulés
plusieurs éléments de réponse ici donc
premièrement pour les retraites les
transferts les rachats du désert de la
ftq
c'est déjà très encadrées donc je vous
invite à aller consulter le site
internet du fonds parce que ça peut
vraiment varié d'une situation à l'autre
rapidement c'est sûr que si vous êtes à
loeb de l'acquisition d'une maison ou
que vous êtes éligible au régime de
programmes pour retourner aux études
supérieures
si vous êtes en pré retraite
effectivement ça pourrait être une
option de faire un rachat d'actions
cette question l'homme m'amène à vous
ramener à l'importance d'un portefeuille
équilibré
donc oui c'est soit que les actions de
la ftq c'est en cause des avantages
fiscaux qui sont qui sont associés à
l'acquisition ces actions là mais si
toute votre portefeuille hier est
concentrée dans les actions de la ftq on
a un exemple ici que vous n'êtes que
votre risque d'en fait est trop
concentrée dans une catégorie d'actifs
donc j'espère que pour les clients qui
pose la question que le real n'est pas
uniquement concentrées dans l'est dans
les actions de la ftq parce que c'est un
fonds d'allusions je vais une assurance
collective pour les frais de médicaments
et autres frais médicaux maintenant au
chômage frise encore assuré où dois je
m'inscrire au régime de médicaments de
la ramq eu donc de façon générale si
c'est une mise à pied temporaire
la plupart des garanties vont demeurer
en vigueur pendant la mise à pied
temporaire puis c'est quand on
licenciement donc un congédiement pertes
d'emplois total que là ce moment là faut
se réinscrire au régime de l'assurance
maladie du québec parfait autre question
est ce que le gouvernement pourrait dé
geler l'argent dans les cpg
les certificats de placement garanti
pour qu'on puisse y avoir accès en fait
je ne prononcerai pas sur ce que le
gouvernement devrait faire ou ne pas
faire
je vous invite à consulter votre relevé
d'investissement et certains postes
dépôts garantis qui peuvent être achetés
avant le terme
par contre vous vous devez savoir que
vous allez perdre le rendement qui était
prévue à la fin du placement donc de
leur disons classement initial
donc c'est vraiment ça dépend du produit
vous avez en main parfait autre question
d' encore du temps le gouvernement
pourrait-il nous permettre de retirer
jusqu'à 5000 $ de nourrir non imposables
le beau cadeau un jeu encore une fois je
me prononcerai pas sur ce qu'ils
devraient faire ou ne pas faire pour
gérer la crise
première des choses donc évidemment si
les investisseurs ont des épargnes non
enregistrées
si vous avez un portefeuille celi on
s'entend que d'un point de vue fiscal
vous devez privilégier le décaissement
du scellier à vendre ailleurs la
particularité dans la période actuelle
c'est que bon on peut toujours des
questions reyers on est en diminution de
revenus donc on va tout simplement
ajouter le montant du retrait à sa
déclaration de revenus de 2020 par
contre actuellement dans le marché
actuel c'est que le risque c'est
encaissé des pertes
donc on va vérifier avec eux
avec son conseiller financier s'il n'y a
pas d'autres portes deux options avant
de procéder à un retrait de rien aucun
second parce que les régimes de retraite
à prestations déterminées sont en danger
en fait l'origine de prestations
déterminées ils sont de plus en plus
rare et c'est justement à cause de la
situation actuelle donc c'est très
difficile de prédire le marché
actuellement mais ce sont des fonds qui
sont gérés de façon très prudente et la
correction boursière je lui répétais
déjà ici mais ça fait deux ans qu'on
l'anticipé donc les gestionnaires de ces
fonds là ont préparé des stratégies et
étaient prêts probablement à cette
correction à l'ouest qui aura des
conséquences à moyen long terme
c'est difficile de dire à l'heure
actuelle parce qu'on est encore comment
on ferait des comptes est encore devant
trop d'incertitudes absolument merci
samedi la chapelle
ça me fait plaisir